[Music]
hello, how are you, greetings, andrés gonzález,
with your pre-information for today,
Wednesday, August 25, we remind you that
tomorrow is the last draw for the
bucks nevada days incentive program, this
means that people only
have two more days to obtain the vaccine
against kobe and thus be able to participate
to win the top prize of 1
million dollars, there will also be other
cash prizes, scholarships and passes to
state parks, all the details can be
found on our univision.com page,
the section in Spanish
if you are interested in  get
the coitus vaccine and you still don't know where to
go we tell you that there will be some
vaccination clinics for today
around the valley one of the clinics
will be catholic charities of southern
nevada starting at 10 am
in the center located above las vegas
boulevard near the intersection with owens another
clinic will serve you
from 7:30 to noon near freemont e
eastern for a l  full view don't
forget to check out our disney
dotcom page spanish section
[Music
] las vegas flights partner with
credit one bank this season they
work for a new initiative
called one for the coming and well the
discount what is it about craig one  bank
will donate 2 thousand dollars for each
extra point of the bellos during the
regular season at the end of the season
divided in all proceeds between
voice en gros clubs in southern nevada and
articles stops
and we will see the weather forecast
we will have another dry day  and hot in the
valley with temperatures reaching
104 degrees there will be some breezes in the
afternoon the heat will continue with temperatures
reaching 108 degrees for the weekend
remember to drink lots of water and not be
exposed to the sun for several hours
have a nice day  Say hello to
Andrés González and he can about the
News Now newscast in Spanish
[Music]